a sequence is simply a set of numbers in
a particular order or a set of numbers
which follow a pattern the most basic
example of a sequence is that of
counting numbers 1 2 3 4 and so on the
numbers follow an increasing pattern the
three dots mean the list goes on forever
and are referred to as the ellipsis the
numbers don't necessarily have to be
continuous to be a sequence a list like
0 5 10 15 and so on are also said to be
in a sequence what's the pattern here
every number is increased by five to get
the next number a constant increment of
five let's take an example of a sequence
which has an increment of two like 1 3 5
7 9 and so on for your exams
there are just two things you need to
know about any sequence first how do you
find the nth term of a sequence and
second how do you define the sequence
what do I mean when I say the nth term
say I asked you the 31st term of the
sequence you have no time to write all
the 31 terms to find that out we need to
have a formula and yes we have one it is
the first term plus n minus 1 times D ft
is the first term and is the term number
so if we want to find the 31st term we
just substitute 31 in place of n and D
is called the difference between any two
continuous terms it's called the common
difference it's extremely simple to
derive this formula but you don't really
need to know it for your exams
so don't dwell too much over it in this
example as the first term is 1 and the
common difference is 2 the nth term will
be 1 plus n minus 1 times 2 how do we
define a particular sequence we just
solve this for
the expanding this gives us 2 n minus 2
and we add the 1 this gives us 2 n minus
1 here n takes the value of all natural
numbers
don't forget n is the term number if we
call this sequence s the first term of
the sequence will be written as s 1 to
find the first term all we do is
substitute 1 in place of n we get 2
times 1 minus 1 and 2 minus 1 gives us 1
now with this formula try foiling the
ninth and the 21st term of the sequence
the 9th term will be 2 times 9 minus 1
which equals 17 and the 21st term will
be 2 times 21 minus 1 which equals 41 41
is the 21st term of the sequence so to
define the sequence we just use the nth
term formula and substitute the values
of the first term and the common
difference we will look at a couple of
sequence examples in the next part of
the session
you